and that sometimes the experiences we
can create
can be detrimental if not dangerous
to our democracy to to equity in our
society
to so so many things
[Music]
thank you for joining 20 minute leaders
how are you today
thank you so much for having me i'm good
thanks it's it's a wonderful pleasure
and i'm i'm addicted to thinking about
user behavior and use of research so
this is
you know this is like an entertainment
for me right now these next 20 minutes
as if i'm watching my favorite tv show
i'm very excited what are you calling
from right now
i am in mountain view california right
by the google headquarters
lovely so i'm not going to do a service
to you by by
reading the whole the whole introduction
i'm going to let you talk a little bit
about your journey but
you know just for the year you know
you're a leader lead researcher within
airbnb previously in the idc and the air
force and a bunch of other companies
along the way
most recently now uh heading the user
research at wealthfront
a company that i that i d played myer
actually i believe the founder of
wealthfront was one of my professors at
stanford
about financials and he's also about
this uh
so yeah you know norm take me back
why user research why is there
experience and what
is what is user research in its core
well i kind of i would say got into
the realm of ux by chance i was born and
raised in israel
though i sound suspiciously british
because both of my parents are
um and and i serve in the military
in a unit within the air force which is
in charge of israel's missile defense
systems
and when i left the army after five
years or so
i uh joined elbit a company in israel
which it builds a lot of things it's
part of the military industries
i joined the team building those same
missile defense systems i was operating
in the military
and my interest and my focus was on the
user experience of those systems
except we didn't call it user experience
at that point
and i didn't have that much expertise if
any
really besides being an operator of
these systems
um and then throughout the rest of my
career since then i've
mainly just been trying to build my
expertise specifically around
research and so at some point i decided
to um
leave israel move to the u.s to central
illinois
amidst the colon fields of illinois and
get my phd in psychology
really and really yeah and
and really level up my research skills
that way
um but at some point i realized
throughout that
my passions are tech and research and
the marriage of tech and research is is
the field of ux research
and so i'm really glad that i got to
move to silicon valley where i know you
typically live as well
um and work for these incredible
incredible companies
airbnb intercom and these days well
found here what what does it mean though
to enter a company as a user researcher
because at the end the company you know
there's a there's a bunch of different
functions that you think of when you
think of a startup or a big company
right all the way from the research and
development
all the way to the financials and to the
strategics and the marketing
but the user research user experience
field it sounds to me a little blurry
about where that flies is it in
marketing
is it in research in r d where is that
so a couple of things first of all the
way i think of it is
and you know this there is incredible
talent
here in silicon valley and across the
the us and
israel of course and there are also
these days we have
access to every single imaginable
resource we could need to build
anything right servers are cheap and
graphic
graphic cards are cheap and memories
cheap
and and we have tools coming
out of our ears we have so many tools we
have everything we need
but just be hot but just because we have
all of those resources and all of that
talent
doesn't mean we should just build
anything it doesn't mean
every idea has equal value and it
doesn't mean that that idea
will serve people
so we need to understand
people we need to understand how people
think and how people behave and what
attitude people have
because ultimately any successful
startup
any successful startup starts with a
problem a
deep meaningful problem that possesses
people
and founders of those companies and
ultimately when you solve that problem
in a way that makes sense
thanks to among other things research it
makes all the difference in the world
and that's what creates incredible
companies
now ux research is typically under one
of two kind of
organizational umbrellas to your
question either the design team
or the product team depending on on the
company
so i've reported into both um these days
my manager is the vp of designer wealth
fund but i've also reported into product
in the past it really depends on the
organization so what does the job
actually entail because
you know a lot of people run by
intuition when they're developing a
product or they're thinking of a product
they're imagining what the user will
want
they're taking that assumption and
they're just developing based on that
how what is the impact that a research a
user researcher can have an
organization so the problem
most founders tackle is that they are
not
their users sometimes rarely you
may be your user um
but usually you're not and so you need
to go to your users
this is something that paul graham
famously told the airbnb
founders when they waltzed into his
office for their you know weekly meeting
when they went in y combinator
and he asked them where are your users
and they told him you know the 20 or 30
users we have at that point
are all in new york or they're mostly
new york so we said you know what are
you doing here
go to your users go to new york talk to
them and
they realized so many things from that
trip one of them famously
was that the places that the hosts were
hosting in their their
homes their apartments they weren't well
photographed
and people weren't really getting to see
and imagine the you know the awesomeness
of these places they could stay at
so joe gabbia one of the founders of
airbnb
ended up photographing the host
department
and that was the beginning of a very
important characteristic of airbnb which
was
beautifully presenting hosts homes and
apartments
and ever since then ever since then and
and before then where whether it's at
airbnb or anywhere else
user researchers in particular have been
going to
users and that can be done through a
variety of methods right it can be done
in normal times we don't have a pandemic
in person by
traveling to users all over the world it
can also
be done in much more quantitative
ways such as sending out a survey
or or watching users as they as they use
a product
but whatever method it is ultimately we
go to our users because we recognize
that we are
usually not them and we need to
understand
how they see things right and i believe
that for you know from the
from the very small experience that i
have in years of research and
in my military service i was responsible
for building products that hopefully
intelligence people will love using
and part of the part of the challenge
that i faced was going to these
users and i would know who my users are
they definitely weren't me but i knew
who they are
and i would sit with them and i would i
would ask them a lot hey what do you
need
why is this difficult for you what would
you like to see and there's the famous
quote right if 100 years ago
you would ask people what like how like
what they need to get from point a to
point b
they would want faster horses so how do
you tackle that
you know as a researcher when the people
that you're talking to don't even
necessarily know what they want and you
almost have to
you know read between the lines and
extract that aha
that's exactly the point we all we often
talk about in our field that
we are not trying to establish what
people want
we are trying to establish what they
need and again that all starts with a
problem
we're not looking to people for
solutions
we're not asking people who you know
have a carriage with a horse
what they want because they would save
faster horses
what we're trying to understand is you
know the fact that you only have a
carriage with a horse
what problem does that create in your
life you know is that problem that
you know your is it that you're not able
to get from point a to b
fast enough or is it something else
perhaps
and so i'm not sure what led you know
ford
and the original car makers to to make
the car but
i can imagine it's some of those
problems so the key here is
where you keep your focus and most
research frameworks
help you focus on the needs and the
problem not
what people want again right we have
incredible
incredible talent here amazing designers
amazing engineers
we can take care of that stuff we just
need to understand what the problem is
the underlying problem
so when you attack when you approach a
challenge and i'm assuming that
a lot of the times you're approaching
these challenges and you have to start
from scratch and you have to get to know
what the product is get to know who the
potential users are
and get introduced to a whole new domain
what is your process
how do you go from a to z and
understanding to then
give some concrete feedback to whether
it's the vp
product or vp design whatever it is on
how this product
should be actually you know built or
thought of
yeah so first of all it's a very
collaborative process
and that's something that is is just
growing i would say in the research
community
um we work in cross-functional teams we
work with designers and engineers and
pms
and it's important to mention that and
we start broad
right we look at the market we look at
the competition
we look at what exists today we do lots
of secondary research not just
primary research so primary research is
when you actually go to a user and ask
them questions
but secondary research is just looking
at what we know from academia looking at
what we know from competition looking
what we know from a bunch of different
a bunch of different things um and then
usually start
more on the qualitative side by simply
talking
to people because we don't know what we
should even be asking them in the first
place
we don't know what they're trying to to
tackle
um for example a few years ago with
wealthfront this was about
finances right this was about investing
you mentioned
andy was your professor at stanford um
it's one of the most popular classes at
stanford i think the the classy teachers
and he realized that
young people especially uh you know the
sort of people that were his students at
stanford
didn't have access to
investing tools to the same
sophisticated tools
that used to be only you know for the
wealthy and the very well to do
right um who would have imagined
ten years later that you could leverage
tools like tax loss harvesting even if
you don't have
a million dollars in your investment
account you know
so this this is a this is a a
paradigm change or this was a paradigm
change in investing
and and uh and just one one of many many
examples
is this an industry that's evolving the
the the industry of user research and
user experience
do you see from the when you started to
wear this today
is it more popular or have the methods
evolved
it's maturing a lot so first of all the
experiences we're creating
are so much more complex than ever than
ever before we are able to
build incredible software these days but
those experiences are very very complex
and so more and more research is needed
in order to craft them
we're also slowly but surely
transitioning to
completely new platforms that people
have never experienced
um you know my kids who are five and one
right now
they're not going to drive cars and
they're not going to use
huge phones like caillou because there's
a limit to how big you can make a phone
screen
and they might live in some mixed
reality which i'm not sure exactly what
it'll look like but it's coming
and so you have more and more complex
experiences
you have completely new platforms up and
coming platforms which require
a whole new understanding of
human perception human abilities and and
new problems that these platforms um and
in addition the field has been showing
in other ways
for example one of the things we've seen
on the development side
and the design side and the research
side is the rise of ops of operations
devops design ops
research ops as researchers these days
we have so many more tools and processes
and and things to take care of and so
the field of research ops has been
really burgeoning in the past few years
and then one more thing i feel like i
have to say is that
i think we have also come to realize in
the past few years way too late
if you ask me that we have great
responsibilities
in tech and that sometimes the
experiences we can create
can be detrimental if not dangerous
to our democracy to to equity in our
society
to so so many things and so companies
are thankfully investing
more than they have before in doing that
research as well
and making sure the platforms are are
accessible
making sure that that things are more
ethical
than than before more equitable than
before
that's another important component of
what we do with
researchers well and obviously
and being a user researcher at a wealth
management
you know company in that space it's a
lot of responsibility it's a lot of
responsibility not just for the company
to continue succeeding and knowing its
users
but it's also responsibility for knowing
what the users actually need and how to
create
you know the light moments that are
actually beneficial to the users and not
detrimental to them
and i i took a lot of inspiration from
one of the classes i had at stanford
by floodgate it was a venture capital
class we were talking about these
delight moments that these that a lot of
companies are trying to create
and and it's it seems that not all of
these the light moments are actually
beneficial to the users
they could be sort of artificial they
could lead them to
it to behavior that are that's going to
be bad for them in the long run
and i i couldn't agree more about this
but this burden of responsibility that
is seeming to just
you know being of an exponential rise
this understanding
especially given what we've seen in the
past a few years
uh in all domains nom what do you enjoy
most
what do you love most about what you do
which part of it well first of all to
your point
and i think this will answer your
question i've had some
kind of strange experiences in my career
um when i started
working on the missile defense side i
was a small part
of developing something that i hoped no
one would ever use
which is a very strange experience right
building something you hope
no one uses because if they're using it
it means there's there's a war
um and it means that you know your
country and its people are are in danger
so that was strange and fast forward to
today
um you know i'm helping to develop a
system where
unlike so many other systems these days
where it's all about
engagement and making sure that people's
eyeballs stay on on a screen and
watch more ads perhaps in our case to
your point
you know sometimes to do what's best for
people
it's actually about not just delighting
them
keeping them engaged with software it's
actually
helping them avoid making mistakes
and taking actions that could be
detrimental to them and
and to that end i think what i love the
most right now
is just the the foundational impact
that research can have within an
organization
and the foundational impact that a
product like welfare can have
on people's lives it's it's really
really meaningful
and it's incredible to be part yeah it's
incredible to be part of that
that ecosystem and and have even a a
small
impact on on the way things get built
you know we are i i think that
broadly speaking in tech and certainly
at wealthfront
we are trying to serve people our
mission at wealthfront
is to put people above institutions to
serve people
um and that's not something that has
traditionally existed
in in the financial space or any space
really and as someone who is obviously
curious
about people and understanding them or i
would not go through
you know the path i did it's such a
delight for me
that we are more focused on people than
ever
before and we truly just want to serve
and i know that you know we have
rightfully in tech
being criticized um certainly in the
past few years
for many things that were absolutely
wrong and there's still so much to work
on but i'm a techno optimist
i am i am optimistic about our impact
i think that broadly speaking um
you know and certainly when it comes to
what's in our hearts and what's in our
minds and our intentions
we we want to do great things we want to
impact people's lives
in a positive way and give them access
to tools
that haven't existed before and it's
amazing when you think about it you know
when i think about education because i
have young kids
and watching them go through the
education system now
there's still so much to do and so much
to improve
and as i watch just going through a
global pandemic a terrible pandemic
which has cost
way too many people's lives i can
envision all of the incredible things
that are yet to come
that could improve our healthcare system
and when i see companies like
uber and lyft and other companies trying
to revolutionize transportation
and i think about the future of kind of
urban
life and how we won't be hopefully
wasting so much space on parking lots
and and and parking structures and
and commuting and
drunk driving and and all of these these
things
if they become something of the past
that that's an amazing
amazing thing so i'm very excited and
that's the best part i think of being in
my role and
just in tech in general and i have to
say that after this conversation i'm i'm
even more excited than i was before i
consider myself a techno optimist and i
love that word i haven't heard it before
and i'm adopting it so thank you for
that
and i'm and i'm and i'm energized by by
your vision and the way that you
perceive it and
and the shared response the shared
responsibility that you outline here
that i really hope to to take with me as
well along
along with whatever ventures i get to
work on nom this has been such a
pleasure thank you very much for
being so generous with your time before
we leave i have to apologize and put you
on the spot one time
and ask you for three words that you
would use to describe yourself
and i and i have to put techno optimist
as one of them
i'm a that's for sure
yes techno optimus for sure um the
second would
certainly be extroverted i am an
extremely extroverted individual i am
struggling to to exist in a time when we
are so disconnected
from our friends and family and each
other
um which is part of why it's such a
pleasure to talk to you there are many
reasons why it's supposed to talk to you
that's one of them just to connect with
other people is always fun
and and the last one i would choose is
curious
i have always been just a very very
individual um i think i
i credit that to my mother in particular
i think of kind of
gifting me with curiosity and a love of
reading and a love of learning
and it's the main reason why i'm a
researcher i'm just a curious
person no this was such a pleasure
thank you very much continue doing good
for people and
and i can't wait to see what what next
things you do because it's just
it's just remarkable thank you very much
thank you today